- Honestly, I think
many, many people
would be far better off not
going to university at all,
and I think it's an important
point for me to make
because here I am part of a
team founding a new college.
It might make it seem like I
think college is the answer.
I think by and large
most, if not most,
very, very many
people can and should
and will lead higher and
better and more beautiful lives
by not going to college.
And we need to
remember that, right?
We don't want to become a
place that somehow thinks
we're all just minds, or
that everyone has a mind
that is good at
thinking about this.
We have people who,
in the true diversity
of the human race, many
people who are doing
many different kinds of
things, and most of them,
by the way, don't
involve going to college.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and we
are at the Locals studio
here in Miami, and I am
joined by Stephen Blackwood,
the Co-Founder and
President of Ralston College
in Savannah, Georgia.
Stephen, we're almost
dressed exactly the same.
It's nice to see you.
- Good to be here, thank you.
- So we've only done
one show together
in my many, many years
of interviewing people.
So I want to talk
about Ralston College,
a place of actual learning,
from what I understand.
And Jordan Peterson's
intimately involved
in what you guys are doing,
so I know this will be
interesting to my audience.
So first off, give me a
one minute bio on you,
how you ended up
starting this place,
and then we'll talk about
what's going on over there.
- Gosh, well, in some
sense I'm just a farm boy
who discovered big
ideas and the difference
that education made in my life
and that I believe can
make in the lives of many,
the role it plays in a culture.
So I had my own
trajectory educationally.
I studied philosophy
and classics,
worked in the inner city
for a while, lived abroad,
did a PhD in Atlanta
at Emory University,
and basically, sort of
with the other founders
of the college, sort of
surveyed the landscape
of higher education, in
which there are many,
let's say, chronic
and systemic problems.
- That would be one
way of putting it.
- Well, you know,
let's maybe understate
rather than overstate, but yeah,
let's say the
problems are serious.
But rather than focus
on the problems,
we thought, well, maybe we
can do something positive.
What could we do?
It's always easy to kind of
bitch and complain about things,
and frankly I think
there's too much of that
in our world generally.
And so we thought, well,
let's see if we can
do something better, more
beautiful, more wonderful,
more transformative
for students.
And that was
essentially the impetus.
- So how you got on my radar
was Jordan Peterson said to me
do you know this
Stephen Blackwood guy?
Do you know what's
going on at Ralston?
And you are here actually
in Miami right now
because you're doing the
Biblical series with Jordan.
You're about to finish
it up this afternoon.
Before we do all the
Ralston stuff and education
and all that, can you just
talk about the Biblical series
and what that's been like being
with these cast of characters,
Shapiro's been there,
and Prager, and a whole
bunch of great thinkers.
- Well, I mean, I think this is
a really interesting
phenomenon, frankly.
As everyone knows, Dr.
Peterson, one of his first
really big works was
a series of lectures
he gave on the book of Genesis.
And I think the story
is he just thought
that maybe it was possible that
this kind of perennial text
that people had been reading
for more than 2000 years,
was there a way it might
speak to a wide audience?
He just gave it his best shot
at trying to make sense of it.
And I think the story was
that he just booked a theater
for 16 nights or
something, and it sold out.
And I think that's actually
quite an important moment
in Dr. Peterson's
own thinking through
what his own vocation is and
what the work of our time is.
I can't speak for him of course,
but I think it's a pretty
simple formula in a way.
There are all kinds of
wonderful treasures,
things figured out in the past,
great books, works of art,
ways of understanding,
cultural, let's say,
cultural wisdom that
it's just there.
It's just there.
I mean, we're not
living in a place,
the situation is not
that we're in a desert
or we're at the
beginning of time
and nothing's ever
been done and we've got
to figure out how to do it all.
The situation is as
if everyone's hungry
and you're told
there's nothing to eat,
there's no food,
we're in a famine.
But actually go over here, and
you open this door over here.
There's the biggest,
most beautiful feast
ever known to man all here,
anything you could imagine,
the most beautifully prepared
and gorgeously grown produce
and so on and so forth.
I don't believe in the metaphor,
but the point I'm making
is that in fact
we've got this tray.
You could change this to
think we have no beauty,
and say, well actually, look
at all these amazing things.
So the point is a simple one.
It is that I think
the Exodus seminar
has been born of a
very simple insight,
and that is that these
works that human beings
have found
transformatively insightful
to make sense of their own
lives for 2000, 3000 years,
that they can still speak today.
And rather than simply tell
people what they're about,
what happens if we just have
a conversation about it?
Does that come alive in a way
that it then comes alive for us?
And and my experience
in this last week or so
that we've been here is
that this conversation,
which I would say has very
low to no levels of ego,
which is sincerely just
trying to figure out
this amazing text and see what
we can understand about it
has been a really beautiful
and memorable experience.
And it's a very interesting
thing to note, Dave,
that there appears to be
a wide audience of people
who are hungry for that
kind of non-instrumental
not reductively political,
richly expansive deep content
that says something to
them about what the nature
of human life is.
- To bring that
metaphor to everything
that's going on in
the world today,
I mean, it sort of feels to
me like we've been wandering
in the desert with a lot
of lies, a lot of untruths,
half truths, a lot of confusion.
But there does seem
to be a promised land
on the other side of that,
where people are
seriously talking about
how to rebuild things,
how to get us to that land
where there is goodness
and all of those things.
What's your role
specifically at the table,
because everyone sort
of has a little bit
of their own expertise, right?
- Yeah, I think that's right.
My background really is in
philosophy and theology.
So I'm a kind of a
history of ideas,
what are the fundamental
questions kind of person.
But I would say in this seminar,
I found myself turning
again and again
to ask the kind of
almost personal question,
what does this say
to me right now?
And I suppose I think that's,
in a way, the big question.
I'm also aware that on
the Daily Wire Plus,
there's gonna be a lot of
people listening to this
not simply for, let's say,
academic or scholarly reasons.
They're trying to
figure out their lives,
just as I'm trying to figure
out mine and we all are.
So I think what I've
tried to do, at least,
is trying to approach
things from that angle.
- All right, so let's
bring that conversation,
this wandering in the desert
we all seem to be doing,
to why you would start,
co-found a school.
I mean, a lot of it is
because the information
is all nonsensical, right?
Everyone in the world
seems to be wandering
in that desert academically,
and there aren't
many promised lands.
Did I set this up
nicely for you, or what?
- I think it's very important.
I think actually
Exodus does give us
really fundamental
language of the landscape
of our own experience, right?
We all, in some sense, are
living in states of longing,
or you might say the desert,
the place where we're
trying to find our way,
we're confused, we're
battering around,
we're lonely, we're
alienated, whatever,
we've got our personal
issues and so on.
And then the question is, well,
how do you make
sense out of that?
And that is I think, in a
way, what the book of Exodus
is itself, at least
taken historically
by people of various faiths,
to be a kind of revelation
about how one can
move from that state.
And it doesn't come
down just to ourselves,
by the way, either.
But relative to education
and the founding
of Ralston College, what I'd
say is a couple of things.
First is at a big
systemic cultural level,
I think we've got to be
really honest with ourselves
and say right now,
the West generally,
the United States and
any other country I know,
so by and large the countries
of North America and Europe
principally, we do not now have
the mechanisms of transmission
for our own culture.
So let's take the constitution
of the United States
or the forms of building
things that are beautiful
or the forms of ritual
that have defined life.
You know, in profound ways,
these have been eroded
or degraded or
abandoned or forgotten,
and one cannot overstate
what a problem that is.
You cannot have a culture
without mechanisms
of transmission of that culture.
It's like imagine you're
French or German or whatever.
If you stop speaking
that language,
it's gone within a generation.
And so all the
culture really is,
the late philosopher, Sir Roger
Scruton put it beautifully.
He said in a way a culture is
just the things we have loved.
But you know, the only way
something that we have loved
gets transmitted is by teaching
someone else to love it too.
And right now, instead of a
kind of, not slavish obedience,
but humble openness and
respect to the past,
has been replaced in many
respects with ignorance
or antagonism, or this was
just a history of oppression.
I think, well, this is a
profoundly insidious way
of regarding all of the
things that human beings
up until now could teach
us if we would just listen.
So I make that general point
about the systemic thing
because I want to be very
clear that this is not
kind of window dressing, or
we could kind of have this
or have it that way.
I'm talking about the
most fundamental reality
of the world in which we live,
and the very conditions
of human flourishing
as they've been understood
in the United States
and in the West.
I would say those have
been or are forgotten
in fundamental ways.
The next thing I would
say is you can have this
sort of analysis that
there are problems
in this field or this
field or that domain
or in this industry or whatever,
but even a good grasp
on the problems,
a good kind of
critical understanding,
that only takes you so far
because you can't build
out of a negative vision.
You can't build
out of criticism.
So I often give the example,
I make no bones about the fact
that I don't like
brutalist architecture.
I think it's ugly, I think
it's soul destroying,
I think it's alienating.
It has no way in to
understand yourself.
It's kind of demeaning
rather than elevating.
But you know, not liking
brutalist architecture
allows you to build
exactly zero buildings
that are different, right?
You've got to say,
well you know,
I'm for a certain
vision of proportion
and symmetry and so on.
So what we're trying to
do is something positive,
and that positive,
I want to just say
to the third point
I want to make
is you can talk about systems,
you can talk about positive
vision and everything,
but do you know what?
At the end of the day, this
comes down to individuals.
And the way you
transmit a culture
is by giving
something beautiful,
a form of deeper and
richer self understanding
to an individual, and
that you might say,
is meant to be what the heart
or the core activity of
Ralston College is about,
about giving something
transformative
in a free and beautiful,
non-instrumental,
non-coercive way
to help people contend
with the most fundamental
human questions, and
that takes various forms.
- Are you surprised
that more schools
aren't doing this, or abjected
their duty to do this?
Or is it obvious
because it was the end
of all of what we now call woke,
that these ideas got so
into all of the schools
that it's pretty obvious they
were all gonna end up this way
and that you'd have to
start a school like this?
- Well, I think I'd just
say very quickly two things.
The first is that this is
a multi-factorial problem.
There's a long history,
and you can talk about
the vocationalization
of the university,
that it's partly to do
with trying to educate
a much wider swath of
our country and culture,
and that's a noble instinct.
But it's also kind of
shifted the university
towards more marketing
and less art history
or something like that.
And so that's a question.
And then you've got the
whole student loan crisis,
the way the federal government
is radically distorting
these things and not
only leading to inflation
and things like
that, but essentially
there's no normal market
corrective on a poor product
because the federal government
would just give anyone
anything they want just
to study at university.
It's a disaster.
We actually have way
too many people going
to get degrees that
are often not worth
the paper they're printed on,
or not finished or whatever.
You should look at
the completion rates.
It's unbelievable nationally.
And then you've got-
- How bad are they?
- I don't want to mis-speak,
but there are many places
in which dropout rates
are well over 50%,
I think I'm not mis-speaking
to say well over 50%,
or incompletion rates.
And so that's to say
people not finishing
the degree they started.
But they still have a loan
for the money that they spent
on the time that they
don't get degrees.
- Ironically, with some of
the stuff they're learning,
it's probably not the worst
thing if they're not finishing.
- Honestly, I think
many, many people
would be far better off not
going to university at all.
I think it's an important
point for me to make,
because here I am part of a
team founding a new college.
It might make it seem like I
think college is the answer.
I think by and large,
most, if not most,
very, very many
people can and should
and will lead higher and
better and more beautiful lives
by not going to college.
And we need to
remember that, right?
We don't want to become a
place that somehow thinks
we're all just minds, or
that everyone has a mind
that is good at
thinking about this.
We have people, in the true
diversity of the human race,
we need people who are doing
many different kinds of things,
and most of them, by the way,
don't involve going to college.
All that is to say that
in what we're doing,
we are seeking to be
grounded fundamentally
in a positive vision, and
relative to this historic arc
of what's gone wrong
in higher education.
You can analyze this from
any number of different ways.
There's the woke
and the ideology
and the politicization
of education.
It's a huge problem.
And whether it is inevitable,
I think actually yes it is.
I think there is no continuity
without sort of
birth and rebirth.
You can look at any
industry, any time, anywhere,
and I think in higher
education in the United States,
if you want to
really get into it,
these problems are not new.
You can go back to,
it's kind of an urtext
for many small C conservatives,
is William F. Buckley's
"God and Man at Yale".
It was written in 1950 or '51
or '52, or very early '50s.
That's 70 years ago.
You can look at the most
famous book in this regard,
is Allan Bloom's "Closing
of the American Mind",
written in 1985.
I mean, that's a long time ago.
You say, well, what have
we done in this time?
And I think broadly
speaking, people thought,
well, we can kind of
reform from within.
And I think we should never
give up on a great institution.
It would be nihilism
to give up on something
that has been meaningful and
could still be meaningful,
but at the same time, I
think we have to admit
that that strategy has
been an abysmal failure,
because during the time at
which we've been supposedly
trying to do things
internally, I would say
the situation at
the universities
has gotten far worse
in that time than better.
And so the point
is finally to say
that I think the current
situation is like the one
I gave with the
example of hunger.
Because let me just ask
you whether you would
agree with this, because you
speak to a lot of people,
you have a good
sense of the pulse
of a whole generation of people,
and multiple generations.
I would put it to you that
the average 15 to 25 year old,
or 30 year old, whatever
you want to say,
when they're trying
to make sense of life,
when they're like, oh gosh,
dealing with cancer or death
or suffering or depression
or my addiction or whatever.
When I'm trying to
make sense of my life
in the deepest way, like the
thing that matters the most
to all of us, is like
can we live a life
that we regard as
worth living, right?
There is no more
important question
for human beings than that.
I would put it to you that
at the top of the list
of the places that they would
look is not the university.
- No, I mean, I agree.
- And what that means is
that the place that should be
one of the most obvious
places you'd turn,
the repository of
all human learning
and the humanities, which
are nothing but the record
of what other human
beings have thought about
their lives in the past, which
is one of the key sources
to try and understand our lives.
The point I'm making
is that the industry,
broadly speaking,
higher education,
has taken such a wrong turn,
that the thing it should be
most known for, people
don't even turn to it for.
It would be like the
last place you turned
to fill up your car
was a gas station
because they no
longer had any gas.
- It almost seems like it's
the complete reverse, actually.
- Yes.
- It's the 180.
It's not that it's
just slightly missing
or they veered off slightly.
They actually give you
none of those tools.
They teach you a whole
other set of things
that have very little to do
with the lessons of the past.
- In many places, sadly
I think that is true.
You may end up worse off
intellectually, spiritually,
morally, by having
your mind corrupted
by a certain kind of
very downward looking
cynical nihilism that really,
and I don't think I can
say this strongly enough,
because I'm not a political
or instrumental thinker.
I think we know
that there are ideas
that are really
toxic for your soul.
And they lead to bad
places psychologically,
relationally, intellectually.
And that's a bad place to be.
- So when a student
comes to Ralston,
and you guys have a grad
program right now, right?
And this is where you
just went to Greece
with how many kids
did you go with?
- My first class, we opened
admissions this year,
our first program is
a one year intensive
Master's in the Humanities.
So it's kind of like
an intensive boot camp
going through the
history of the West.
It started with two full
months of intensive study
in Greece of Greek, so
it was kind of boot camp
in language learning
meets the grand tour.
It was amazing.
A full two months.
We started in Athens,
then a month in Samos,
the island of Samos, a trip
to Constantinople, Istanbul,
and then the last three
weeks in partnership
with the Harvard Center
for Hellenic Studies
in Nafplio in the Peloponnese.
So yes, we had a
really intensive on
the ground encounter
in the place in which
the ideas and ideals,
you might say
originated in the West
in the language in
which they originated.
It's no mistake that
philosophy, theology,
astronomy, biology, these
are all Greek words.
So it's not just a
kind of historic,
oh, that's kind of interesting.
It's like these are the
categories of thought,
categories of what does
it mean to be free,
what does it mean
to be autonomous?
There's another Greek
word, self ruling.
That's where it starts.
So there's a real
sense in which Greece
and the language of
Greek has always been
kind of like a
source, like a well
that perennially enables
us, if we attend to it,
just as many other things,
history of religion.
I'm not saying it's all
about Greece all the time,
but it's a core aspect
of Western culture
since its early stage
in the 5th century B.C.
- I did see the movie
"300", and I'm pretty sure
that's why they were always
taking out Athens, right?
They were pretty pissed at
these people who had ideas
and were doing good things
and spreading freedom.
I mean, I'm half kidding,
actually, but not fully.
- No, I think if the
battle against the Persians
had gone differently, the
series of famous battles
that the Greeks had
no business winning.
It's like these massive
forces of the empire
descending on a little group
of this band of citizens
who just said, give me
freedom or give me death.
If they had not
won those battles,
well, there would have been,
I think we can say confidently
there would have been
no Western culture.
The ideas of Greece would
not have made it out
into a wider sphere
that wouldn't have been,
you might say, the seeds
that laid the groundwork
for the whole Roman empire.
They were the seeds
that transformed
the Christian revelation.
They were the seeds,
in some respects,
they were the
ideas through which
frankly all of the
religions of the book,
Christianity, Judaism and Islam,
at certain points of history,
have all been reading
their books, their holy
books, their Bibles,
through the lens
of Greek philosophy
and the categories of thought
we were just talking about.
So the point I'm making is that
you cannot really overstate
how influential that moment is,
because in a significant way,
it is if not one of the
sources from which the whole,
you might say trunk and
tree of what we now call
Western culture grows.
- So you bring these
students there,
and you were telling
me the other night
a little bit about
the rigorous process
to just get in the program
in the first place.
So they go there, they
learn about the humanities,
they get the keys to
this great knowledge.
Are most of them thinking about
what they're gonna do after?
Because one of the
questions I get on this show
all the time when
we do Q and As,
I get from parents who are like,
first off, they are
very leery about sending
their kids to college
in the first place.
Then the second question
is where do I send them?
And the third thing
is is anything
that they're gonna learn
there gonna equip them
to be out in the real world?
If you're teaching kids
all about the humanities,
it's wonderful in
terms of a full life,
but are they thinking about
what they want to do after,
or is it almost not that
important yet in some regards?
- Well, I think.
- Because you're going
just purely for knowledge,
it sounds like.
- Yeah, I think this raises a
really interesting question,
Dave, because I think we
have to think really honestly
about what is useful, frankly.
And I would begin, my
starting position would be
what matters the most to a
human being has got to be
at some level what they
regard as most important.
That's what enables them to
have that perhaps most useful.
And I really would put it
as a fundamental contention
that there is nothing that
matters more to human beings,
we're self conscious creatures,
we don't just live as automata.
We think about ourselves,
we value things,
we feel bad when we do things
that we think we
shouldn't have done,
we have hope and
dreams, we love,
we love beauty, we
gather in community.
What I would say is there
is nothing more important
than giving a human
being the tools
for them to regard their
own life as meaningful.
And that doesn't come down
to simply material things.
I mean, you can have
all the material wealth
and success in the world and
feel like you are poor inside.
You can not have
the relationships.
No one gets to their
death bed saying,
oh gosh, I wish I just
made a little more money.
I mean, they get to
their death bed saying,
they're still thinking
about things like
why did I never reconcile
with my brother,
and how could I have done so?
And so I really want
to explode this idea
that the humanities are
somehow, and I'm not saying
you're suggesting this,
but as if they're somehow
this recherche
thing, oh you know,
we've imagined an English
accent or something.
We're at a cocktail party
talking about something
that no one gives a damn about.
No, I'm talking about the
fundamental questions,
truth, justice, love,
beauty, forgiveness.
How do these things work?
What are they?
And that's the bedrock.
And so I'd say that, but
then I'd also say something
more practical
towards your question,
which is it's easy to
think that the best way
to do something
practical is practical.
And in fact, this is the
really interesting thing
about the humanities.
If you subordinate them
to a practical
instrumental outcome,
like you say I'm
gonna read Shakespeare
because it'll help me
to teach marketing,
it'll help me to learn how
to sell razors or something,
it's gonna fall through
your hands like sand.
You're not gonna
have anything left,
because you're not
gonna get anything
out of damn Shakespeare
if you read him that way.
Whereas if you really attend
to this amazing understanding
of the human condition,
you really get into that,
well you know, that may
make you quite powerful
when you start thinking
about what motivates people,
how do we speak to people.
I'm not saying this is gonna
help you sell a million razors,
but it very well may.
And so the point I'm
making is that if you don't
subordinate it practically,
it becomes
unbelievably powerful.
I mean, let's just be
honest about the fact
that the kind of education
I'm talking about
is in fact the education
that has basically defined
statesmen, politicians, the
movers and shakers and doers,
in many respects, of
our whole history.
So it's actually a
very recent idea,
and I think it's profoundly
mistaken to think
that the way in which you
can do something important,
even in the real world,
is you've got to start
by understanding that
world fundamentally.
- Right, well that's why
it's so interesting to me,
well, I guess it's interesting
but obvious at the same time
that Jordan is
involved with you guys,
because the tools that
he's always talking about
for someone to take
their life seriously,
well, if you study the
humanities honestly
and really get an assessment
of history and everything else,
and then you have a
little of the history
and the knowledge before you,
and then you start doing
those things yourself,
then I think to your point,
in some ways that is the
tool set that you need,
regardless of what you
studied specifically,
as per a vocation.
- Yeah, I think that's
completely right,
and I think when
you look at, I mean,
our students, they came
from tech and from teaching,
from the art world,
from a range of both,
you might say, pretty
hardcore practical
to education and so on,
and I think their careers
are likely to be
as diverse as that.
But just even to
speak as an employer,
and I know that as you are,
you can't just
take it for granted
that someone can
write a sentence
in our current day
and age, right?
But speaking as someone
who hires people,
it's actually very
important that you be able
to convey not only
something grammatical
and not riddled with mistakes,
but maybe of a certain tone.
Imagine how valuable that is,
if in your life you're
able to be a kind of master
of how you present what you say
so it can be maximally
well taken on
by the person
you're saying it to.
That's about the most
useful thing you could have,
particularly in a so
called knowledge economy
we're living in now.
So I don't want to undersell
the really practical side
of a rigorous
humanities education.
But you don't get that
if you don't approach it
with serious rigor
in the first place.
- Just a couple more we
can do somewhat briefly.
I assume you're getting
probably calls every single day
from professors who are like,
I cannot take this anymore.
Hire me, please.
I mean, is that part of
what your job now is?
- Certainly, and we're
really looking forward
to continuing to add to
our team as we expand.
There is a lot of
dissatisfaction out there.
We've had, of course,
hundreds and hundreds of CVs
over the months and
the last few years.
That, I think, is fundamentally,
it's really interesting
to ask why that is,
and I think it's because
there's these people
that they actually
dedicated their lives,
because they said I
want to be part of this
sort of beautiful transmission
and opening up the minds
of the young to things
that will help them.
And often they find
themselves in positions
in which they don't feel
they can speak their mind,
they're ostracized
by their colleagues
or fearful of speaking openly,
where they're under pressure
to politicize their
own classrooms.
Its just a sort of
sorry position to be in,
where you're not able to
really devote yourself
to the high order things that
inspired your own vocation.
And we hope that, not
only do we look forward
to hiring many of those people,
but we also hope that
in some even small
and maybe not so small
way that what we're doing,
what other new
institutions are doing,
may play some role
in recollecting these
other institutions
back to what they're all about.
- How hard is it building
new institutions?
I mean, I know a
little something
about building new
things on the tech side.
It's tough, and you
will get pushback
in every possible
way you can think of,
and a whole bunch that
you cannot think of.
But you still do it.
- I think it's very
hard, is what I think.
I'm not gonna sit here and
pretend it's been easy.
Of course, we've
been very fortunate
to attract a network of
support and friendship
and people who are behind us,
but that took years to build.
And I think it's
worth saying that
that, I think, is also a symptom
of something that's gone very
badly awry in our country.
In the 19th century, there
were something like a dozen,
25, if you look at the
numbers, they were starting
new colleges and
universities at a real clip.
Every few months,
there was another one.
They're the ones we
have now, by the way.
Most of them were started
in the 19th century.
And you've got to ask
yourself what has gone wrong
when on some of these
really core issues
of what we are as a culture,
we've lost the dynamism
to recreate and reinvent.
There's a kind of surrender,
a kind of capitulation
to well, what can we do?
And it's kind of like
you're on the Titanic, man,
and you're saying, well, I
guess let's just go down.
I mean, do you see
what I'm saying?
I think we need to
be able to recover.
It's sort of like
remembering yourself.
You're sort of in lethargy
or depression or whatever,
and you remember,
you come alive again.
I think that's what
we need as a culture.
And I don't think you can do
that if you have pessimism
and grumbling, and
why would you do that,
or I've often heard, oh,
you could never do that.
And I think, do you know what?
Yes we can.
- Yeah, yes we can.
There was a politician who
probably isn't on board
all the ideas that you're
teaching over there
that used to end
with yes we can.
So that might not be
the perfect ending here.
So instead, tell the good people
where they can go if they
want to find out more,
and we'll put some
links down below.
- Yeah, well we'd love
to have your listeners
check out our website
at www.ralston,
R-A-L-S-T-O-N, dot A-C.
Sign up for our newsletter.
We have online
lectures and a podcast
and various other things.
What our highest
hope here, Dave,
is not that this is just a place
for however many students
we grow to have over time,
but that it can also
be a kind of fellowship
for anyone who seeks
the truth with courage,
and we would love to have
anyone who's listening
join us in that.
- Now that I've softened you up,
you can go talk Bible
with Jordan Peterson.
- All right.
Thanks for having me.
- You've got it.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about academia,
check out our academia playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.